i always do think it's very valuable to
talk about those bumps in the road and
how you overcame them so
when that kind of blissful ignorance
went away
do you remember the first point that
kind of i don't know like hit you like a
truck in a sense where you're like oh
like oh my god like i don't know if i'm
gonna get past
whatever it is uh not booking an
audition not having a film pan out the
way you hoped anything at all
yeah i mean like because i moved to los
angeles when i was
19 and i moved out on my own and i
didn't really i
knew no one um but i was doing it
because
i didn't want to leave new york i mean
i'm from new york i love it there
i don't live in you know yeah i was
living in the city i was living in new
york city at the time
um but i thought well this is going to
help me
this is going to help my career so i got
to get out there and i did and you know
i did like my first pilot season
which was really intimidating and a lot
of pressure but i
was very close to booking that that old
tv show lost
which was very exciting
because um you know basically it was
like it was the whole cast
that you see on the show and me and i'm
the only
i think i'm the only one that didn't get
a part in it and at the time
i was really bummed um
but what i learned was like about a week
later i
auditioned for brokeback mountain and
while my role in brokeback mountain is
very small um i wouldn't have been able
to do that
or even audition for it if i had booked
lost so
i do think that like that taught me
that a lot of the times if you're not
booking something it's because
either you're gonna learn something
somewhere else or there's another
job out there that just wouldn't be
happening if
you know if you booked this one and you
know brokeback will forever
be one of my favorite movies of all time
and
one of the most special things i'll ever
be a part of i think